ah ouais oh là
là je sais pas c'est qui qui a filmé ça
quoi jamais vu ces images non j'ai
jamais vu C
image c'est
ouf la C elle est en option de
bâtard non mais là c'est ouf vasy c'est
ouf parce que cette cassette c'est
d [__] nique sa mère elle a
cramé ah ouais là tu m'as tué là tu m'as
tué je me suis retrouvé comme un enfant
tu vois qui regardait les vidéos de
l'époque maintenant j'ai plus qu'à
prendre mes B et aller faire aller faire
un petit méro pour me détendre waouh je
sais pas où tu as chopé ça ça m'a remis
le sourire je sais pas si je vais tu
vois si mon sourire je vais réussir à le
qu'est-ce que ça t'évoque en regardant
ça ah mais tout toutes toute l'histoire
du
graffiti
[Musique]
vandale on est des vandales quoi on est
des salisseurs graffiti Vandal c'est
c'est l'essence même du de ce qu''est le
graffiti
c'est interdit ça a pas de sens mais
c'est ce qui me plaît quoi c'est
certainement la discipline la plus
respecté c'est la liberté faire ce qu'on
veut break c'est un mélange de peur
d'adrénaline d'excitation donc tu joues
avec ça tu joues à te faire peur quand
tu quand tu fais du graffiti c'est des
trucs dangereux c'est illégal c'est
interdit par la loi tu fais pas que pour
la beauté de du résultat tuessayes de
mélanger un peu tout ça et c'est ça qui
est beau dans dans le
graffiti le vandalisme c'est pas
forcément cassé c'est élaborer quelque
chose de propre de construit dans un
hors cadre logique pour
nous c'est un groupe
d'amis au point de vue local et à
l'internationale c'est une
Internationale de graffiti on va dire
dans le point commun c'est un certain
[Musique]
style
c'est des lettres géantes principalement
en chrome avec un contour les plus
grosses poss possible le plus stylisé
possible pour pouvoir impacter avec
visuellement le plus de
[Musique]
frappes sont nul CIA quoi je connais pas
c'est les mecs les plus nuls du
monde céit moche à l'époque qu'est-ce
que c'est moche aujourd'hui prendre ça
c'est une phase ils vont la prendre
merde alors les UV eux leur style il av
carrément pas de style c'est c'était un
peu du grand n'importe
quoi c'est un style quoi qu'on a
développé sur sur plein d'années
quoi les UV c'était un groupe qui était
principalement un groupe pur vendal ça
pour nous c'est incompréhensible ça
arrive à
rien ce qui est sûr c'est que je cherche
pas la technique ça j'ai jamais cherché
la
technique ça m'intéresse pas en fait
c'est pas ce qui me parle moi ce qui me
parle c'est plus le côté spontané quoi
en fait de la peinture on se prend pas
la tête mec tu sors tes bombes tu traces
tu remplis avec des couleurs moches si
possible du
marron et c'est ça qui est beau en fait
quoi si c'est pour aller saloper de la
bombe et la vie id bêtement je vois pas
l'intérêt il y a plus de force à
chercher l'énergie et la spontanéité
dans une peinture que chercher la
technique en fait c'est deux mondes
complètement différents moi je me
souviens même qu'il y avait des mecs qui
disaient [__] mais ces mecs il
peignent de la main gaucheah ouais si tu
veux quoi mais
non si on paignait comme ça c'est qu'on
le faisait exprès on savait ce qu'on
voulait faire et et tant mieux si ça
vous choque vous savez que c'est super
CR chez vous il y a plein de trucs
partout
la merde quoi je finir ta
cl je m'appelle Robin je suis connu dans
le graffiti sous nom de Shadow et s j'ai
fait partie de plusieurs groupes don les
UV originair d'b dans le Val
d'Oise j'ai fait du graffiti pendant 10
ans de 89 à
2001 manière assez intensive quasiment
presque professionnel complètement
passionné bousillé par ce
Tru mes parents ont toujours su hein ce
que je faisais on s'est on s'est
beaucoup parlé tu vois c'est il y avait
pas d'interdit ils savaient que je
sortais du cadre mais au moins ils
étaient au courant de ce que je
faisais moi j'ai toujours été très
observateur j'ai toujours observé des
des graffitis qui n'étaient pas du grap
en fait des slogans politiques des trucs
lié aux cultur musicale hard rock skin
punk et en fait il y a un petit jeune du
quartier avec qui je me fais copain qui
m'invite chez lui un samedi après il me
met dans les mains ce Boyart estpr
CANART et je découvre ces bouquins et je
me prends une grosse claque en fait
quoi il y a cette photo qui est
magnifique où tu as un mec qui court sur
les toit des métro et celle-là je me
souviens qu' celle-ci elle m'a vraiment
marqué parce que c'est ça représente la
liberté en fait ça me donne de la force
ça me donne envie en fait quoi je me dis
ça bouge il se passe des trucs
le déclic dans le graffiti pour moi ça a
vraiment été le visionnage de envoyé
spécial un reportage qui date de ouis
90 dernier volet de ce magazine Les
tagurs j'entends déjà certains qui
hurlent au vandalisme et d'autres qui
crient au génie même si ça vous dépasse
accrochez-vous et dites-vous simplement
que c'est peut-être l'une des formes de
culture de cette fin de
[Musique]
siècle tout le monde avait l'info tout
le monde attendait les graffeurs on
attendait tous ce truc
[Musique]
quoi Paris couvert de tag Paris massacré
retourné cartonné comme disent les
tagurs André sur son scooter les 93 MC
qui font un train quelques minutes
suffisent au 93 NTM dans l'entrepôt
désert de la SNCF repigne le r à leur
couleur
ça ça partout et qui cartonne tout quoi
et voilà c'est ça le style quoi on
croyait les jeunes gavés de télé avoutis
par le Top 50 et les voilà qui prennent
les armes bombes et marqueur en vendre
partout on va vous expliquer quelques
vocabulaire le flop c'est des lettres
flop quoi des boules c'est plutôt rond
un peu gros quoi il y a le Botom c'est
les lettres carré quoi là je fais des
Botom des lettres carrées tu vois je
coupe dedans ce que je veux non mais
franchement leur partage il est mythique
c'est du pure plaisir quoi c'est de
l'adrénaline pure enfin là c'est tu sur
ton fauteuil tu il tag sans relâche
depuis 8 ans pour la RATP c'est l'ennemi
public numéro 1 fils de bonne famille il
est devenu voyou juste par amour des CIN
lettres de son nom B A n d o bandau
préfère aujourd'hui rester dans l'ombre
voilà l'important c'est qu'on mon mur
pas moi une fois qu'on commence c'est
fait fin quoi genre c'est plus possible
d'arrêter bande c'était vraiment c'était
bah c'était le King bandoeau c'était le
King de son époque dans les années 80
jusqu'au début des années 90 le mec est
partout dans la
[Musique]
rue très franchement en terme de ce que
nous on aimait c'était le
[Musique]
meilleur pur sty de lettrre très
américain aès new yorka c'est quelqu'un
de propre et qui va faire un nombre de
grafes incalculable en terme de volume
je crois qu'il y a rien qui pouvit
battre bango et son équipe pour moi
bandeau c'est un des c'est un des
premiers c'est un précurseur ça a été
une révélation pour beaucoup et il a
insufflé l'envie de peindre énormément
de vits dans
Paris
[Musique]
je te laisse je te laisse t'asseoir tu
me regardes et puis tu
présentes je m'appelle Philippe Leman
[__] j'ai pas vu le
filmuseux merci
pH
je m'appelle Philippe lman j'étais un
des premiers à commencer les graffiti en
Europe en France et je tag
[Musique]
bandau ma mère habit à Paris donc Paris
au lycée en France mais mon père habitaé
à New York donc depuis tout petit
j'aller prendre les vacances d'été à New
yor mon
père je voyais toujours des graffiti
partout mais je savais pas j'adorais ça
c'était vraiment stylé mais je savais
pas exactement ce que c'était en je
comprenais que c'était des gens qui
écrivaient le nom machin mais je
comprenais pas trop le délire et un jour
j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer
be be 167 lui il m'a expliqué ce que
c'était comment il fallait s'entraîner
comment il fallait commencer les règles
du jeu entre guillemets après je suis
rentré en France où il y avait aucun tag
pas de graffité machin mais je mortel et
c'est parti de là et j'ai pas arrêté en
fait
c'est rouge c'est
parti dans cette histoire de graffiti
j'ai toujours eu un coup d'avance parce
que j'ai j'ai géré ça comme une
guerre début 84 j'ai appris que le métro
de Paris serait l'attaque l'objet d'une
attaque de graffiteur en fin d'année
pour que de points ouvrir les guilm
paris devienne New York fermez les
Guilmet du point de vue de l'Artp céit
un vrai problème ça moi j'aurais été
chef l'Artp franchement j'en a rien à
[__] quoi mais en essayant de
l'arrêter ou ne pas essayant de
l'arrêter le résultat est le même j'ai
réuni une quinzaine de personnes des
médecins des psychologues des chimistes
pour poser la question comment gère-t-on
les graphiteurs s'ils
débarquent ch
[__] je sais ce qu'on va faire va mais
déjà parle pas là pendant que
çaenregistre déjà premièrement arrête
d'être un con ouais il fallait savoir
qui c'était et pourquoi il faisait ça
donc il fallait pour parler crument les
infiltrer ça je sais pas non ça je me
rappelle pas pas non donc j'ai demandé
un cabinet de détective privé de se
charger de ce boulot moyennant la
rémunération qui allait
[Musique]
bien monsieur faut frotter dur ça dépend
sur lesquels oui ils ont vraiment pris
ça super au sérieux genre comme si on
était des terroristes presque moi je
prends ça réellement comme un compliment
parce que ça veut dire qu'on fait bien
notre travail le résultat est arrivé on
les a identifié tous sans aucune
exception sont des enfants de famille
éclaté c'est-à-dire il y en a pas un qui
vivait dans une famille normale papa
maman et les enfants non ça c'est pas
vrai ça il il y a eu plein de mecs qui
font des tags évidemment qui sont issus
de famille éclaté machin mais ça a
absolument rien à voir avec le problème
le ténor des ténors le nommeré bandeau
ayant ses parents un à New York et
l'autre à Sydney par je pas c'est sorti
ça ça c'est n'importe quoi donc en fait
faire des graffitis c'est un problème
psychologique d'isolement et de manque
de reconnaissance de la personnalité de
la part d'une
famille quelques mois après l'un de mes
types a eu une idée le
dag dispositif
antiraffiti effectivement ils ont
développé un truc un peu grisseux donc
quand tu peignais dessus en fait la PE
la peinture accrochait pas ça c'était
l'arme absolue contre contre les
graffiti si vous
voulez c'était un truc donc en fait il
fallait juste taguer autre part et donc
on a commencé à vraiment défoncer
partout et à faire réellement encore
plus de dégâts parce que quand tu te
défonces sur un mur un peu poureux
machin là c'est vraiment galère à
[Musique]
effacer donc ça a arrêté les graffiti en
quelques mois
grâce à cette
invention vous avz gagné la guerre pour
moi
oui qui s le vent récolte la
tempête en 91 elle a v jouer jouer les
malins là et ben voilà ça veut dire que
les T maintenant t veulent s mettre
voilà ça
veutquer la plus belle station de Paris
mort ils ont planté le drapeau sur la
lune c'est un symbole du vandalisme en
fait réellement et ça c'était mortel
madame monsieur bonsoir 1er ma 1991
j'allume ma télé comme tout le monde les
Tigers ont frappé là où ça fait mal et
aux informations on parle que de ça on
les appelle des Tigers la station de
métro Louvre l'une des plus belles de
Paris été victime la nuit dernière de
tager la station Louvre a été vandalisée
incroyable jamais vu jusqu'à
présent la station entière souillée ou
selon les avis embellie par un
foisonnement de nuage multicolore que
l'on nomme tag bombage ou graffiti et
les images sont choquantes clairement
même pour un graffeur donc nous c'est un
choc apprécié mais la station elle est
juste défoncée quoi la station Louvre
était la plus belle du métro parisien
maintenant les tagurs exposent à côté
des reproductions de chef-dœuvres
antiques sur les murs et sur les stat un
mélange des genres qui ne plaît pas à
tout le monde ils ont juste touché la
France entière ils ont fait leur action
pour choquer et ils ont réussi quoi ce
qui était plutôt intelligent parce que
ça arrivait directement sur le musée le
plus connu au monde c'est l'histoire de
France ici donc la plupart des Parisiens
n'ont pas supporté ça c'est coup de
maître génie tout d'un coup ça a mis un
énorme coup de projecteur sur ce qui
était le graffiti Vandal cable de
laisser faire des des choses pareilles
je ne comprends pas pourquoi des des
gens veulent s'extérioriser en habillant
tout notre patrimoine tout en sachant
que toutes les statues qu'il y a dans la
station lou c'est que du toc c'est
important de rappeler que c'est des
copies c'est pas des avoirs original
évidemment c'est pas la peine de faire
le Guignot on veut leur couper la tête
moi j'ai dit on leur coupe des mains
leur couper la tête on le on le on leur
donne des C oui on leur fout des chiens
au cul c'est comme un braquage qui passe
aux infos il s'était fait la pub la plus
dingue du monde quand ils ont fait cette
station ça va continuer vous croyez je
sais pas je sais pas mais à mon avis ils
s'arrêteront pas comme ça ils vont tout
[__] là ils vont tout [__] en 91 tu
l'urais fait toi à l'époque non je pense
pas non non je pense pas non non
j'aurais pas fait parce que là c'était
aller au devant des emmerdes vraiment
d'ailleurs ça a été très rapide parce
que il on commence à parler de lui un an
avant un an après c'est terminé c'était
C prison terminé parce que les mecs ils
ont été au trou quand même AC pour
[Musique]
ça chaque fois quand tu
rentres attention c'est pas bien de pre
sur des métros franchement je trouve ça
stupide mais c'est de
tu vois il y en a ils font des motroises
et des trucs nous on [__] la
[Musique]
RATP moi 2 jours avant je réunis tous
les plus tagurs actifs de
Paris et là il baltrin tous je dis
écoutez moi j'ai fait deux trois nuits
de
repérage moi je baltrin pas qui même me
suivent et on a
[Musique]
kiffé on sait que ça va partir en
couille on sait ce qu'on fait mais là tu
vis vraiment un moment
présent très agréable d'ailleurs tu vois
c'est comme le sexe c'est un moment tu
t'oublies on fait des trucs stylés
quoi eux ils nous imposent des affiches
qu'on a pas voulu nous faire consommer
tout ça et tout tu vois bah nous on
impose notre
art tu poses tes couilles sur la table
on l'occurrence sur les rails et tu vas
peindre des [__] de métro le métro
c'est technique il y a police il y a
truc et tout c'est chaud le métro ah
c'est chaud le métro je faire une
chanceon la top action en France dans le
Graf c'est le Louvre deeno pour moi
c'est mémorable c'est le c'est le best
quoi en fait en voyant ça je me ça m'a
décomplexé je me dis ouais après j'ai
envie d'aller faire des des grafes sur
les voies Ferré vers chez moi tu vois en
91 tout le monde s'y
met les petits les grands tous les
lycées tout tout le monde qui prend le
[Musique]
métroop en 5e je fais des tags sur mes
cahiers sur mes feuilles en 4e je passe
plus dans la rue sur le chemin du
collège tuas un marqueur ou une bombe et
tu tu técris ton
nom et un samedi j'ai essayé d'aller
faire un métro tout seul
et je me suis retrouvé devant le métro
il y avait des bruits il y avait du
avait des courants der du vent des trucs
pas loin d'une
station en fait je me suis pas senti je
suis reparti quoi j'ai pas trop de bruit
trop de pas j'étais pas assuré j'étais
pas bien quoi c'est c'est la peur on
appelle ça la peur je pense
quoi quand je fais mon premier
train il y a un mec de ma ville qui le
voit ce mec là il s'appelle Fabien en
terminus à la garde bois colombe il y a
des grafes dessus et je vois un Chad qui
a un diminutif de Shadow en fait mon
premier blaz vraiment c'est Shadow
Shadow c'est un peu long donc j'avais
compris que le mec faisait Chad et je
lui dis j'ai vu ton train il avait fait
un train avec de potes avec des potes
j'ai vu son train passer avec des Graf à
lui on se met à discuter et on sent
qu'il y a une passion commune on se
connait pas mais on m'a dit que tu
faisais Shadow moiuss je fais du tag je
fais du Graf ah ouais ch is truc de
dingue enfin tout de suite on se il y a
un truc quoi et ça va être le début
d'une euh d'une très longue
histoire notre but avec Fabien à cette
époque là c'est de de tout découvrir
d'aller dans le plus d'endroit possible
on est des gamins on a une passion
commune on vit le truc mais sans trop se
poser de questions je pense quoi on on
vit vraiment le le le le la
passion nous sommes dans le plus grand
podé de
Panam nous sommes dans le plus grand
podé de Paname on va jusqu'en banlieu
sud jusqu'à juvizi pour aller dans des
casses parce qu'on a entendu que là-bas
on pouvait peindre des trains donc on
peint des
trains ch
i dès qu'on peut on laisse une trace tu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vois
[Musique]
la nuit MEP il ferme la station une fois
que le service éta
fini il y avait espèces de grill une clé
la clé 11 c'est la clé qui permet
d'accéder à pas mal de de portes du
métro cette clé là était universelle
c'était la même clé pour toutes les
grilles de toutes les stations du
réseau un peu le qu'il fallait avoir tu
entendait une copie tout le monde se le
repassait pas il y a eu beaucoup en fait
de mecs qui se sont procurés les clés
qui sont fer dans les station et qui
payaient dans les station moi
j'utilisais la 1001 pour froder le métro
en fait quand les gens passaient au
tourniquet mettaient leur carte orange
ou leur tickets au tourniquet moi
j'ouvrais la petite porte comme un agent
RATP sauf que j' j'éis un gamin de 14
ans quoi c'est bien des années après que
j'ai demandé à des gens qui
connaissaient un peu l'URP j'ai dit mais
pourquoi vous avez jamais changé ne
serait-ce que les clés parce que si tout
le monde les a c'est pas la peine de se
plaindre que les mecs qui viennent pour
tout taguer la nuit et les types m tout
à fait honnêtement m'ont dit mais
changer les clés ça coûterait tant de
millions d'euros parce qu'il faut tout
changer les grilles les machins effacer
les graffiti ça nous coûte quelques
dizaines de milliers d'euros et donc ils
ont laissé pendant des années les clés
tout simplement parce que c'était pas
cher
quoi c'est une clé qui permettait
d'ouvrir énormément de porte dans la
RATP dont la ligne 7
bis des métro bleu vraiment à l'ancienne
des années
on pousse la le petit portillon jaune
sur lequel il a écrit descente
interdite on descend les tro marches en
métal on est dans le tunnel quoi il
suffit de longer le mur et on se
retrouve derrière le
[Musique]
métro je me rappelle très bien sur le
métro sur la j'avais
écrit pas de règle pour moi et mon CRE
quoi le support le plus compliqué à
atindre c'est le méro parce que est
sterrain c'est un réseau très
sou-terrain et que les dépôts ne sont
pas forcément visibles et accessibles à
cette époque là il y a pas internet donc
pour te renseigner sur les lignes de
métro tu as un truc c'est d'aller voler
des bouquins à la FNAC sur la
RATP tu as des plans des bifurcation de
là où il y a les dépôts donc tout ça
c'est plein d'accumulation potentiell
d'informations sur le réseau que tu ne
vois pas toi en tant qu' usager tu dis
ah ouais d'accord ici il y a peut-être
un atelier ou un dépôt allez hop on va
on va les repérer donc tu te pè un peu
dans les rails et tu essay de trouver
l'entrée de ce truc là c'est une sorte
de jeu en grandeur nature tu vois les
gens un peu observateurs quand ils
prennent le métro pour aller au boulot
se
balader si regarde un minimum par la
fenêtre s'aperçoiv que parfois la voix
elle dévie elle part dans un autre
tunnel mais on sait pas où va ce tunnel
B c'est ça qu'il faut faire quand tu es
un graffeur tu vas te balader dans tous
ces tunnels qui partent sur le côté avec
un peu de chance tu tombes sur des
dépôts quand tu fais un dépôt faut que
tu rentres discrètement
à l'abri des caméras si possible soit
des caméras qui sont en station soit des
caméras qui sont après dans les
tunnels faut faire gaffe aux infrarouges
qui ont été mis progressivement donc qui
sont des barres des systèmes d'alarme tu
vois que tu peux
détecter après on pète cet endroitl quoi
et on se met à
[Musique]
agfer je F
tout F F F F ça VI mais F [__] mais
pas moi
je faut rentrer propre sortir propre et
à l'intérieur faire du sale
[Musique]
quoi qu'est-ce qu'il y a ouis
ou c'est ça défourillage défourillage en
l'ancienne VO pas pasiss TR on n pas des
P
ouais gros tu sais dis bonjour la
caméra en fait je crois que mon année de
seconde je réalise que ça ça me gonfle
d'être en cours et que j'ai envie d'ê me
balader quoi en fait quoi clairement
dans ma tête j'arrête l'école pour ne
faire que du
Graf
un jour on est approché par par une
boîte de com qui nous propose d'aller
faire des pochoir pour la marque
gauloise qui a envie de faire du street
marketing donc de cibler essentiellement
les jeunes donc de cibler les collèges
les lycées les bouches de métro les
endroits où il y a du
passage est-ce que ça vous intéresse
ouais ok c'est payé combien c'est temp
ok c'est parti on y va
il y a un objectif qui est de faire un
logo qui ressemble un petit peu au
casque avec les ailettes tout ça tu vois
fallait plus cl à la télé fallait plus
qu' en ait à l'écran au cinéma il me
semble des choses comme ça donc il
cherchait à communiquer de façon un peu
détournée tout ça est documenté parce
que on devait prendre des photos et se
filmer au camescope à la caméra pour
ramener une trace auprès de cette boîte
de com qui le transmett à gauloise
et du coup avec cet argent de gauloise
moi je me suis acheté un ordinateur bon
voilà nous on a vu un moyen de se faire
du pognon tu vois donc Cera et le fait
qu'une industrie de la mort comme ça
comme gauloise qu'est-ce que tu en
penses aujourd'hui avec du recul qui
c'est la guerre
quoi c'est rien d'étonnant quoi
industrie de la mort oui ouais ouais non
moi je fume pas je suis pas fumeur mais
en fait j'ai envie de dire si les gens
sont cons pour ass un paquet de clop
avec un pochoir ou sans pochoir de toute
façon il ils sont cons quoi
[Musique]
ah c'est lu hein c'est lui
non à cette époque là il y a un moment
charnière tu vois c'est vraiment un truc
qui va je pense nous souder vraiment
tout ce groupe là comme vraiment une
sorte de voyage un peu d'initiatique tu
vois c'est il se passe un truc
[Applaudissements]
quoi on part à Rome
[Musique]
prend le train le le train de nuit qui
qui va à Rome il y a tous les UV qui
sont dans ce voyage c'est le passage
obligé de tous les graffeurs qui
s'intéressent à la scène graffiti
[Musique]
Europe on est au camping on F des gros
joints et on va faire des métros savoir
que Rome à cette époque là c'est défoncé
le métro il est
déchiré quand on débarque on voit même
des pièces qui datent de 1989 ou 90 qui
sont encore en tact en train de rouler 6
ans plus
tard nous on allucine on a vraiment
l'impression d'être à New York à
quelques kilomètres de
Paris on reste une dizaine de jours
c'est complètement le bordel et on
défonce tout
entendu un bruit
là on s'arrache
quo passe passe
passe mais là on est horrible par
rapport aux gens
là G la rue
là et on va vraiment faire du sale sur
le métro italien en mode parisien qui
taque partout qui graffe et tout et on
va marquer les esprits même des Italiens
qui nous en reparlent des années après
quoi on fait plein de conneries on se
barre du camping sans payer donc on
déménage la nuit avec les tentes on se
travvaille le matin à 500 m dans un
champ entouré de moutons et on va même
ramener des embrouilles de là-bas il
fait chier comme ça ch
on voit qu'il y a des des grafes des
petits panel donc des petits trucs de 2
m car fait par des
[Applaudissements]
français donc on a fait chacun notre
wagon de haut en bas des lettres énormes
donc les petits Panol de 2 m² B on les a
repassé
[Musique]
quoi on s'en bat les couilles tu vois tu
fais un gros truc et ben le petit truc
il sauteent quoi nous il y avait une
certaine hiérarchie tu vois bon bah eu
l'ont mal
[Musique]
pris et donc du coup quand on les a
recroisé à Paris ça a fait des
histoires un jour va y avoir un énorme
rendez-vous eux ils vont venir à 2030 et
nous on va venir aussi à une vingtaine
pour en découdre pour régler les comptes
sauf que nous à cette époque là on
commençait déjà traîner avec des gars un
peu un peu plus c que les autres
[Musique]
gartas ah c'est parti en couille
quoi
[Musique]
je
m'appelle réputation sulfureuse je suis
un peu le la bête noire du
graffiti ouais
[Applaudissements]
oua
ouaou ouaispk bon ben qu' nous voyait
les gens disai non pas eux c'est CR
c'est sale c'est
[Musique]
s nous on avait toujours ce qu'on
voulait si on quoi qu'il arrive on
pouvait être ultra violent mais on
pouvait être encore plus que ultra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
violent quand tu demandes des bombes à
quelqu'un il les a acheté il a pas envie
de te les donner donc au
début on était virulent mais à la fin
euh si tu veux les gens nous
connaissaient comment on était donc il
nous voyaient arriver il déposaient les
bombes et il partaient c'est parti mon
frère
ouis ici CTA
pk à l'uvre regardez bien bienil de put
fils de putee bien admirez admirer les
tous les péd là tous lesauand on
arrivait euh c'était coup de tête
balayette si tu es pas content c'est le
couteau si tu es tu es encore plus
récale citron c'est un coup de couteau
si tu bronches c'est le fling et et
après voilà vaut mieux qu'on reste
là cassez-vous cassez-vous
[Musique]
[__] je faisais pas de différence on
all en faire je sais pas quoi peut-être
braquer peut-être je sais pas quoi mais
et faire du graffiti bah pour moi
c'était
pareil
au retour de Rome c'est lors de cette
grosse embrouille que que débarque les
[Musique]
TPK toutes cette jeunes garde qui
étaient là en mode vraiment
Kera et qui savait qu' av entendu parler
qu' avait ce rendez-vous
là l'événement qui rapproche les deux
crou c'est que les UV ils étaient en
difficulté par rapport à d'autres
crew donc nous on entend ça cette
histoire donc on part directement
[Musique]
là-bas ils sont venus en équipe certains
sont venus avec des trucs bizarres dans
leur sac on saura jamais
trop et là ça part en gifle on les
massacre ça part en BAGAR générale et
des boules du métro Bam Bam c'est toi
machin il tattrape par les ve tap là ça
part en n'importe
quoi après cette histoire bon bah nous
les UV on a les mêmes valeurs les mêmes
convictions donc on décide de fusionner
et de faire
uvtpk le crew
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi ah
tu vois tu vois qu'est-ce qui se passe
là voilà c'est la merde cous regarde
bien ta mère regarde bien ta mère
qu'est-ce qui se passe regarde bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bah uvtpk d'un coup ça faisait si on
doit parler du côté impressionnant
c'était beaucoup plus impressionnant
uvtpk que juste UV ou que juste TPK d'un
coup c'est un dou ça double
l'histoirek 9394 il y a
quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a beaucoup de Crew qui ont pourri
l'ambiance dans la manière où il y a eu
beaucoup de dépouilles il y a eu
beaucoup de violence inuties dans des
endroits par exemple dans des terrains
le mercredi après midi ou le samedi
après-midi ça nous est arrivé où il
faisait les casse-couilles dans des
terrains une fois ça m' arrivé au canal
de
lourc je sais plus si c'était pas bobini
ou
ou canal de lour je sais plus c'était là
on est en train de peindre une pièce et
les mecs sont arrivés bourrés machin
tout
[Applaudissements]
bon je tombe sur des grafeeurs et je le
et du coup bah je prends je prends leur
appareil photo je prends tout ce qu'il y
a je me suis retrouvé face à un gars qui
avait un couteau je ça ser à rien de
prendre un coup de couteau pour
ça et puis sur l'appareil photo il
restait encore des des photos du coup
quand je vais développer les
photos regarde un peu c'est qui à qui
j'ai pris l'appareil et justement j'ai
trouvé
i un grave CIA
aussi je me retrouve avec ses photos et
puis je les stock je les mais je les
mets là je les mets là là ils sont là je
je te les Mons si tu
veux il y a un bon bottom à lui même un
volc
et
PE si tu le vois tu pourras lui remettre
je pense que ça lui fera plaisir ces
photos tu les as depuis combien de temps
15 20 ans tu as quelque chose à lui dire
que c'est un bon graffeur que je
l'apprécie et ce qui est fait est fait
et maintenant on essaie de réparer ses
erreurs en en lui rendant quelques
archives peace Bro ce que je pourrais
lui
[Musique]
dire c'est une première dans les anales
judiciaires une soixantaine de tagurs de
toute la France comparaissent depuis ce
matin devant le tribunal de Versailles
pour des dégradations commises dans les
transports au commun le préjudice s'est
estimé à plus d'un million et demi
d'euros un matin toc toc toc c'est la
police je me fais perquise et ensuite 48
he de garde à vue c'est long 48h ils
disent voilà on a fait une enquête sur
vous les mecs ont accumulé des preuves
sur toi ils vont te sortir tout au
compte goûte on sait que c'est toi on
sait que tu connais hôtel on sait que tu
as fait c on sait que tu as fait ça le
fait que des gens ont parlé sur toi
c'est ce film qui a permis aux policiers
d'identifier en tout une dizaine de
groupes de graffeurs et de tagurs à
Paris Lyon Lille ou Marseille ils
opéraent de nuit pour repeindre des
rames de train des bâtiments publics des
murs du métro et de la SNCF il risque
aujourd'hui la prison l'objectif de la
police pendant cette enquête là c'était
de récupérer les archives il dis ouais
où sont tes archives ils avaient compris
que ça c'était vraiment un aspect
important pour nous que c'était nos
souvenirs il disait toi tu as des
archives tu as des cassettes on les veut
absolument et le fait de nous amputer de
ça il nous tuait quelque part ENF c'est
ça quoi ou
et d'ailleurs ils ont détruit des
archives quoi AVS ont été jusqu'au bout
de
l'idée moi ce qui concerne il on pris
chez moi 3000 photos de boucles de
négatif complet avec vraiment clich
uniqueses ont été en fait détruites par
la
police c'est toute une mémoire qui a été
effacé et c'est une mémoire qui ne sera
jamais retrouvé une bibliothèque qui
Brû non non mais je je fume pas les
[Musique]
têtes mes archives tout planqué j'avais
mis ça chez des potes et à chaque fois
c'était des gens qui avaient rien à voir
avec le graffiti les mec qui savaient
même pas ce qu'il y avait dans les
carton que que je laissais chez eux tu
vois donc quand ils sont venus chez moi
bah il y avait rien à part quelques VHS
à La Conte de graffiti étranger tout ça
machin donc ouais ou une ou deux photos
mais rien de ouf tout ça quoi
cétait un matin ils sont venus ils ont
pété ma porte donc j'étais dans ma
chambre et d'un seul coup je vois les
mecs arriver ils m'ont braqué C flics
qui me braquaient ils m'ont mis les
menottes ils m'ont dit voilà tu sais
pourquoi on vient je B ouais ils font
une perquise vraiment une grosse parqu
c'est qui mec qui commence à bouger
l'étagère et derrière l'étagère il y
avait une cassette qui était tombée je
l'avais pas vu parce qu'il y avait un
petite planche en bois donc tu vois pas
ce qui était tombé derrière et ben
franchement c'était la pire des
cassettes qu'il pouvait
[Applaudissements]
trouver on pouvait voir comment on
prenait les bombes on pouvait voir
comment on dépouillait on raquétait on
voyait nos actions bon Robin il la donne
au policier donc là on se retrouve en
procédure criminelle et c'est de là
qu'on a été remonté qu'on a
fini on a fini en
prison pendant des années je vais m'en
vouloir de ça tu vois c'estd merde
[__] pourquoi j'ai pas vu cette
cassette qui était tombée derrière quoi
ça aa été n'importe laquelle une a ça
mais [__] pas celle-l quoi tu vois
depuis ce jourl on s'est jamais parlé et
c'est dommage d'ailleurs pourquoi là
parce qu'on aurait pu régler ce [__]
de différent
et j'aurais m avoir aussi une
explication que lui qui peut me la
donner les quand viennent jusqu'à dire
que c'est moi qui a filmé ce qu'il y a
sur cette cassette puisquils l'ont
retrouvé chez moi et que le jour où ils
ont
filmé le jour où il y a un mec qui se
fait
dépouiller voilà ils me disent voilà ce
jour-là le mec s'est fait
défénestré donc tu es complices de
tentative
d'homicide je quoi enfin tu vois c'est
un coup là je me dis mais dans quel bail
je suis tu
vois
mais est-ce que c'est vrai parce que
c'est pas ce que les policiers m'ont
dit moi les policiers m'ont dit qu'il
leur a donné en maain main
propre donc c'est con de planquer toutes
les cassettes et il y en a qu'une
justement la plus virolente la plus
dangereuse bizarre je me pose cette
question là moi ce que Roba m'a expliqué
c'est que la police a dit que c'était
lui qui avait filmé ce qu'il y avait sur
la cassette et qu'il est donc complice
de tentative
d'homicide voilà
voilà c'est ce qu'il m'a dit voilà
complicité de meurtre bah voilà tu vois
il m'aurait dit ça je l'urais dit ben
écoute c'est pas de ta faute tout
simplement c'est tu fais pas partie de
ce monde là donc c'est normal que tu te
ch dessus tu m'aurais dit ça simplement
on m'a menacer voilà je t'aurais dit
écoute pas
grave nous on est habitué on va faire ça
tranquille mais pour lui c'est pas un
gars c'est pas un gars qui fait des
allersretours en prison c'est pas un
gars qui qui a
l'habitude voilà d'aller au
[Musique]
commissariat lorsque un juge a décidé de
lancer une commission ratoire et de
faire un énorme
là on savait que les choses avaient
changé qu'ils avaient mis de vrais
moyens le procè de versaill c'est le
proc graffiti je pense le plus long de
l'histoire il va durer 13 ans au total
pendant toutes ces années là tu as une
épée de dameoce de ouf sur ta tête 13
annes de procédure ça change une vie
j'étais sous contrôle judiciaire j'avais
obligation de me présenter au
commissariat une fois par semaine tous
les mardis pour signer un registre en
fait ça c'est un truc que j'ai apprécié
parce que par rapport à ma vie en marche
le fait d'aller au commissariat
j'observais le fait qu'ils étaient
complètement largués qu'il
s'intéressaient pas à moi en fait quoi
enfin le simple fait de voir des Bleus
dans leur quotidien et d'aller signer en
fait c'est rassurant presque j'avais
interdiction de m'approcher d'une
gare fils
Dee c'était chiant c'est une contrainte
de ouf bien sûr on respectait pas tout
tu vois ne pas prendre le métro et le
train c'est compliqué he tu vois moi
j'ai pas le permis donc aller à
Versailles bah ouais j'ai all en
[Musique]
je pense qu'ils sont assez mal organisés
moi il me reproche que 10000 € de
dégâts et la surprise arrivé devant le
tribunal c'est plus du tout les mêmes
montants on avait par tête des montants
qui atteignaient pour certaines
personnes 600000
€. moi je crois que jeis je devais être
autour de 300000 et cetera donc c'était
quand même plus du tout les mêmes choses
je en fait je [__] j'avais jamais
travaillé de ma vie à ce moment-l
quasiment j'avais fait deux trois petits
jobs par-ci par là mais je me projetais
pas dans un histoire de de de de vie où
tu travailles et tu vas travailler pour
payer un crédit je me prochetais pas du
tout en cette vie là donc qu'on me mette
10000 ou 0000 € ou 100000
€ d'amende en fait moi ça me concerne
pas quoi en fait c'est c'est c'est un
autre monde c'est votre vie à vous ça
c'est vous vous pensez que je vous dois
100000 € mais moi je m'en fous en fait
on est tombé à une époque ils ont voulu
mettre un coup d'arrêt à ça euh ça a été
un échec total après 13 ans de procédure
ça abouti en tout et pour tout à une
simple amende contractuelle de 2300 €.
et au final que j'ai jamais
payé il y a quoi sur ton t-shirt never
talk never talk voil il y a un message
ouais il y a un message un gros message
fort ça veut dire ne jamais parler
ça veut dire si on se fait attraper on
balance pas les
copains j'ai rencontréwan et il m'a
demandé de te donner quelque chose pu je
crois que sera toi ah ok c'est quoi ah
c'esttau ah super ok écoute c'est sympa
ça vient ça vient de qui ça ça vient
d'où à l'appareil photo je cisz voler t
dérobé ah non moi j'ai jamais de par
photo dérobé je crois pas non
ça n rajunis
pas on est devenu vieux
mainant ah ça y est et voilà la fin au
revoir comment ça va bien et toi ça
roule ouais tranquille
ouais sont encore à la cave alors du
coup ouais cool bah merci hein j'espère
que ça pas pris la FL arrête mais tu
sais que ça doit faire quasiment 10
pilles que j'ai pas revu les trucs quoi
bah faudrait que je te montre à
l'occasion d'ailleurs ce qu'il y a
dedans ça a l'air tellement secret ton
truc là c'est là Chambé c'est là
mortel comme tu l'as laissé comme tu le
retrouves je met ah [__] mon sac de
gitan
quoi il y a tout là c'est
mortel ça c'est quoi une vieille
cassette bah ça c'est ouais ouais ça
c'est Roma 4 c'est quand on était parti
à Rome là à
filmer il y a quand même une partie
qu'ils ont réussi à choper mais pas
tout faut pas que ça disparaisse quoi
ouais faut que les gens voient ça
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quoi